Let's start off by
going to our settings.
We'll go to accessibility,
click on voiceover,
and then I'll turn
the voiceover switch on.
>> Voiceover on, settings,
accessibility, back button.
>> And I can swipe.
>> Voiceover heading.
Voiceover, on.
>> And that'll advance voiceover.
>> Double tap to toggle setting.
>> Double tapping on the home button,
I can switch to the accessibility blog.
>> Active Chrome, active.
And from here I can swipe
to select different items.
>> New features.
Press link the accessibility blog.
A sample blog to help teach
accessibility topics.
A sample blog post, heavy level too.
>> And when I find something I want
to click on I can just double tap.